how do you figure out your passion in
life so I got a great question for my
YouTube viewers who love you guys Rob
who wrote in to say hi Evan how do you
figure out what your passion is are in
life this is a great question I want to
get asked a lot and as a result I
created an entire zuga guy to help walk
you through how to find your passion and
turn it into a business but to quickly
summarize if you have no idea what your
passion is if you feel like you want to
do something different with your life
you don't like your job you don't like
working wherever you're working and you
feel like you know I want to do
something meaningful but I have no idea
what it is that I love then you need to
explore you need to take time to explore
because often the ideas that come up
through exploration are not the ones are
gonna make the most sense the most
logical sense so let me give you an
example right now I'm an investor and
owner of a salsa dancing company here in
Toronto we teach five six thousand
people a year how to dance salsa and I
became an instructor and a DJ and owner
in the business when I first got into
salsa it was just out of exploration
right I loved ballroom dancing when I
was in university I went with my
girlfriend at the time and she didn't
like it so we stopped and then when we
broke up like hey this is my chance to
go dancing again and I went to go salsa
if I went and looked at that as a
business opportunity right from the
start I would say this is a stupid idea
right like Evan you know nothing about
salsa zero you didn't learn the dance
growing up so you're way behind right
like people have done this almost from
birth like they're learning the music
they're learning the steps and Here I am
you know my 20s starting from scratch I
didn't speak Spanish I didn't know the
music I was too tall right I take big
steps all these thing is going against
me and if I went into that thinking this
is asking
business opportunity I'm rushing the
finite passion turn into a company by
winning with that attitude it wouldn't
have worked I would have done one class
say this isn't a business it won't work
for me and I would have gotten on
something else but because I approached
it just from an opportunity to explore
and see what I enjoy doing I had a lot
of fun I sucked at it I sucked so bad at
at the start but I loved it I love the
people of the community I love the music
I just fell in love with it and it
became a business opportunity for me so
if you have no idea
don't rush into something don't struggle
and stress yourself out to find
something right now because you're
probably gonna make the wrong decision
and I don't want that for you but I want
you to make the wrong decision and put
your money time effort into something
that's not gonna work out because you
rushed into it too quickly so take your
time to explore try different things you
know I tried snowboarding and I loved it
and then I just started to fall a little
bit but I still enjoyed going
I tried rock climbing and I hated it I
went once that was it I haven't gone
back since but I tried it so won't try
something you're interested buy
something try it out get some experience
see if you fall in love with it and if
you do then look for business
opportunity around it that's my advice
believe for those you're watching let me
know how you found your passion let me
know what you're up to leave a comment
underneath because your experiences and
stories can help inspire other
entrepreneurs as well you like this
video thumbs up below click on my face
subscribe to the channel thank you so
much I'll see you soon
you